today we're going to be discussing the
three pillars of success with a very
special guest someone that I've worked
with before a couple of our events he's
really changed the game in so many of
different industries I won't try and
introduce you yourself but Gary welcome
to the show thanks for having me I'm
excited to be here
[Music]
before I go directly into the tactics of
should you make a video should you do a
written blog post or she do you do a
podcast I think the bigger thing is and
I think you get this as well is you have
to reverse engineer who you're trying to
get to you know if your salesperson out
there right now if you're trying to get
to me and so many of you are I get 50 70
bulk emails bulk direct messages bulk
Twitter direct messages Instagram
business cards all sorts of weird stuff
sent in the mail I'm busy I'm busy and
like I'm just not interested in you
selling to me not because I don't like
you because I respect the game it's
because I'm just busy it's nothing
personal
so I think the first thing you have to
do is reverse engineer the person you
know because I'm not in the market to
buy anything I'm gonna be tougher but if
I need certain software if I need
something that's a good time to attack
right so I think the number one rule of
salespeople is to listen know your
audience know what they did if you see
an M&A just happen if you see layoffs
just happening if you see one of their
come if I see Burger King doing
something I'm thinking what does
McDonald's think of rice that's number
one number two where are they spending
time I'm easy to sell to if you realize
that I'm spending time on social
networks but I'm not gonna want you to
spam me in my direct message with a
linked and no context you should be
producing content for me to see it in my
feed I think to answer a question
directly everybody as a sales person has
to figure out how do they best
communicate is it written word is it
audio is it video is it in person and
how to use the digital world in audio
written or video form to create the
gateway drug to in person one thing that
people are very confused by me is I
don't even do phone call sales calls I
need to see you face-to-face I'm
supposed to be this digital guy and I
need to see you I use digital and I use
all my content on YouTube Facebook
Instagram snapchat LinkedIn medium as
gateway drugs to this so I think anybody
who's a sales person whether on trip if
you're an entrepreneur startup and
you're not producing content at
scale podcast video blog blog posts
random Twitter Facebook Instagram
YouTube clips then you're losing that is
unacceptable in 2016 that is losing DNA
if you're not producing content for
social networks and the mobile device
and the platforms on it you basically
don't exist
I look at sales very differently than
the far majority I think way too many
salespeople are patient or impatient I
think way too many salespeople are
transactional I think way too many
salespeople are
lowest-common-denominator
spam blast LinkedIn email bulk business
card business card business card so I
think I've got a different tactic on
sales but don't get it twisted it's what
I am if you're not happy with your
upside if you're not fully fulfilled I
think a lot of what you heard for me
today I'm doing things reverse of you I
think a lot of you are doing things that
are directly in front of you numbers
that they put in front of you you're
trying to achieve that because you have
a beach house you want to buy or go on
that vacation sales is a funny game if
you work in a big company they
manipulate numbers to create your
actions I believe that the best sales
people are doing things in a different
way I think you need to care about the
customer for real reverse-engineer them
and give them what they need and so I
have a funny feeling that for 87.9%
arbitrary number that eighty seven point
nine percent of the people watching
right now I'm a better salesperson than
you because I'm the anti sales person
and I think that's the best sales person
think about that think about how you
give yourself air cover to not do
behavior that a short-term please
understand that the world has changed in
the attention of the person you're
trying to get to is moving into
different places and and and this big
one
stop complaining salespeople aren't
allowed to complain the market is the
market your bosses are your bosses a
great salesperson shuts their mouth and
she goes to work every day and tries to
bring value to the end-user and this
patient and over time wins the marathon
of sales put yourself in that position
[Music]